Jemison
hey back projection cue music and accent
Hollywood legends mr. Stan Laurel and
Oliver Hardy arrived in Britain today as
they embarked on the national tour we're
doing this Lowell waiting for this new
picture to come together I make sure
that this tour gets off the right foot
this time it's amazing that you two are
still going strong still using the same
old material yeah
such a wonderful reception isn't it Eden
it's okay to double X for the price of
one pretty empty last night I guess
people just don't want to see long hard
anymore he's hidden pushing a little too
early you know Stan you could have said
goodbye Oliver a long time ago we had a
good thing going but you had this big
chip on your shoulder because I've hid a
picture with someone else I can sleep
the days when they told me what you did
you're just a lazy ass who got lucky
because you met me lucky to spend my
life with a man who hides behind his
typewriter you betrayed me betrayed our
friendship
yeah Hollow
you cannot go onstage again in your
condition I love you but I won't stand
by and watch this not eat or put you in
a wooden box I just never had us take
this tour I love it vida
[Music]
you're not leaving on your stand the
show must go on
[Music]
when you watch our movies it was just
the two of us each other they never
regret we asked you shouldn't read
reverie anything mr. Oliver hot
I'll miss us when we're gone so are you
[Music]